[Music]
hardy yeah thanks for being with us
people think i'm a [ __ ] i just bought
these sunglasses on sunset boulevard for
a cool 800
[Laughter]
who's the idiot now you've got an
incredible deal there those are
fantastic the mexican guy who sold them
till he told me they used to uh belong
to steve mcqueen
so who's an idiot now i gotta say conan
uh i gotta congratulate these guys i'm a
yankee fan you are yeah we know we know
yeah all right thanks guys but i gotta
say this this red sox team has a very
dear place in my heart it does and
that's because the first girl i ever had
sex with looked like david ortiz
is it called
[Laughter]
yeah maybe well after she took her pants
off big papa maybe i don't know but uh
no picture
[Music]
i'm kidding are you sure it wasn't david
ortiz yeah
this has gone bad very quickly oh listen
yes i love these guys
you got i'm a yankee fan but like you i
talk to these guys backstage and like
you too i think a rodger dirtbag
so as a yankee fan you're not a fan of i
hate a-rod and i know these guys hate
a-rod you can say no whatever but um
i know the deal and you guys do me a
favor as a yankee fan who wants a-rod
out i need you to make him depressed or
something could one of you guys like
bang cameron diaz
and take a picture take a picture and
tweet it to a-rod uh
what is it now obviously
talk about this a-rod hunt
it's a-rod it's it's you want him off
you want him gone from the end you know
he's not he's not blue-collar like these
guys a-rod is you know uh
he's he's an ariadite he's he's just
he's just a off um i i i understood the
second one
some harvard education you got yeah it
wasn't the same harvard you're thinking
no he's the kind of guy he makes 32
million dollars a year and he does the
direct opposite of what we're paying him
for like we pay him to hit the baseball
and then in the playoffs he doesn't hit
the baseball right he strikes out every
single time he's like a guy you pay to
mow your lawn and instead of when you're
only comes over and takes a dump on your
lawn
and the next day he comes over and wants
the money
and you were mowing your lawn you got no
you took a dump on my lawn now i have a
contract
and then and an a-hole agent that says
you have to pay me even though i took a
dump on you
like the old yankees who made like 80
grand a year when they lost in the in
the world series they looked upset they
looked they looked upset and mad yeah
their lives were like ruined because
they had lost the world i mean greg
nettles and thurman munson these guys
like they were great guys all the old
yankees like the guys in the 60s they
had wives who look like me you know
they didn't want to go home
but hey rod
thank you but hey rod
he makes 32 million a year he's got a
private jay's like a corporation yeah
and you're a guy you know a yankee if
you've got a fat kid who has three hot
dogs that's 90 dollars yeah and then
there's parking the tickets you're out
like a grand for the game and you're in
traffic on the lau going back with your
orange vest to work on the highway the
next morning right and the next day you
pick up the daily news and a-rod is in
miami
a model all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then you know i mean come on it's
the truth he could hang around the bronx
for a day and look miserable and i hate
he's got those pillowy pink lips
[Laughter]
he's got those pillowy pink lips i i
think it's a shade of purple
i always it's a shade of purple and i
don't know it aggravates me you should
try it yeah yeah well i it doesn't look
good on a fat guy